um it isn't obvious that people higher  up in a competence hierarchy have fewer  strictures on their moral behavior than  people lower in the hierarchy right  because my sense is that responsibility  increases as you move up the hierarchy  and so and your degrees of freedom with  regards to moral attitude also tend to  decline because you're know if you're a  manager of them maybe you have 30 people  working for you and they each only have  one manager there's a lot of people that  you're responsible to and so and you  can't miss you can't mistreat your  people  with any degree of consistency because  the good ones leave  the bad ones torture you to death and  the whole thing collapses across time  and so the whole idea that what you have  in the a confidence hierarchy is power  is not  reasonable assumption as far as I can  tell that's a big deal right wisely  we've got to get that right well so it